I don't want people to think this has  anything to do with crypto because  really it doesn't it's just a classic  case of human corruption human greed and  fraud so it's no surprise to me that  he's looking at two life sentences  because the most notorious fraudster  Bernie Madoff he got two life sentences  plus 40 years what we're seeing as well  this mess is massively due to the lack  of clarity and the fact that Americans  aren't really expecting any crypto for  any regulation to be coming anytime  sooner so what this does is it actually  pushes these cryptocurrency entities  offshore makes them have to operate in  that gray area which hurts retail  investors